but first up he's an attorney and the
provocative gun rights enthusiast who
hosts NRA TV's noir kolya Anwar I have
seen your videos many times you're very
good at what you do
thank you I am I am NOT a gun lover okay
now if I say the term gun nut I hope you
realize that is not an insult I don't
take it as much good I don't mean not
like you're crazy yeah I mean like
something you really love today I'm
incredibly passionate advice I'm a drug
nut not all drugs just the ones I can
get my hands on okay but when I watch
your videos you know I'm very often you
know at the end you kind of have a smirk
like I laid it out and you know what you
kind of earn your smirk because people
like me who don't really like guns we
don't know much about guns and the theme
with you really I think is like it's
annoying isn't it that people like who
talk about guns and don't know about
guns
yeah I'm not restrained by their lack of
knowledge what are the misconceptions
that bother you the most well there are
two dynamics right there's the actual
physical component of the gun and then
the individuals as we've turned gun nuts
right so there's that aspect of say for
instance semi-automatic right yeah tell
me about that vast majority of your guns
almost all of them are semi-automatic
almost all good right I didn't know that
yeah I didn't know that and so that
stuff you would learn after you follow
the rabbit down the hole so to speak and
semiotic meaning you have to pull the
trigger and once you get one bullet
right and that's almost all gun pretty
much yes not just so there seem to be
obsessed with the ar-15 yes so with the
they are does not stand for assault
rifle that's a common misconception
right
the a R stands for Armalite rifle which
is the red actual rifle and it's a
semiautomatic rifle in the sense that
you pull trigger once you get one you
get one round so why do people think
liberals wouldn't be honest why did they
think that getting rid of the ar-15
would go so far to solving this problem
and tell me why it wouldn't um you know
as the saying goes optics is everything
right right there's a certain theatrics
with guns in general right especially
when you start thinking talking about
things like they are 15 what they are 14
you see it it's big usually most people
who aren't too familiar with guns they
usually know about them by way of movies
so you see the movies with all the bad
guys spraying and praying doing all
these crazy things with the firearms and
then you see that in reality you're like
oh my god I don't want those anywhere
near me or on the streets and so ends up
happening is they take that and then
they see it and it's like well they
don't know much the knowledge base is
not very high so what they end up doing
is they start feeling alright because it
evokes a feeling this is the theatrics
behind it they're loud there's a muzzle
flash you know all of those things and
it could be said we like their is a lot
of hypocrisy there if guns weren't so
popular why do they dominate movies as
much as they do because there's there's
a fascination there like yeah it's kind
of like going to an amusement park right
and that's why I say to gun nuts like
just be honest and admit that you love
guns and it's sort of a vice in that
like you know gambling alcohol drugs and
these are all things that have some
collateral damage then I am willing to
live with because you can't tell me that
I can't smoke pot because some people
will be hurt by it mm-hmm
you know you can't organize society
around what some people might do or be
hurt by completely so you would admit
that you just like guns you're like
holding them you want to have sex with
them
it's multifaceted right so there's an
element of recreation there there's an
element of sport there there's an
element of protection there right and
then there's an element of philosophy
with regard to what this country was
founded on so it's incredibly
multifaceted so winds up happen is just
a lot of people who don't really know
much about firearms have a very myopic
view of them and the only lens that they
see them through is that the are the bad
things that are done by bad people I
feel like it's self-reliance a lot -
absolutely isn't that what you feel I
get that from your videos well it's it's
self-reliance based on reality right do
you you don't trust the cops to show up
it's not that I don't they do they might
shoot you
there's always there's a possibility for
everything right right but that's not my
main concern my main concern is that in
the in the moment right whenever
something arises where I may have to
defend my life I wouldn't be in a
position to do absolutely anything
possible I can to make it out of there
alive along with the people I love and
anybody else who seems to be around that
I care about right but I had killer Mike
here mmm about a month ago who was on
your show and got in a lot of trouble
for talking about guns no he got a lot
of trouble just being on my show just
for just being on the show right but you
guys made some interesting points about
how it's very easy for people who live
in safe neighborhoods to talk about gun
control it's a whole different story for
some other folks who don't have that
luxury yeah I think one of the things
that ends up happening when we start
talking about some of the gun control
measures that people are pushing is how
they disproportionately affect people
who are in lower economic environments
and in environments that have a higher
level of violence right and so like you
stated before I can live in a gated
community have a security guard outside
I'm gonna be feel relatively safe even
then something could still happen but if
say for instance I'm a single parent
mother and I live in an inner city
somewhere and I'm working two jobs and I
can't afford a car and I have to walk
late at night and when I get off work at
night and walk back home
or if I'm at home with my kids in an
environment where there are home
invasions right I as a woman in that
particular in that particular situation
and just anyone
I don't want me protecting my life to be
a competition I want it to be as
lopsided as possible because I'm not the
one threatening someone's life I'm going
about my life and someone shiny
with that and so I'm gonna be in the
best position possible to guard against
that right and I am sympathetic to the
argument that if you're in a horrible
situation it would be a good thing if a
good guy had a gun absolutely and we've
seen many times and I know you think
that they don't report it I don't think
they reported enough in comparison to
right but my question is where does that
lead we can't go back to the Old West
where we're all strapped all the time oh
we are well I'm not I'm sorry there a
gun somewhere around here I hope so
you're right yeah but not everybody
because everybody can't do it I mean you
don't really want teachers themselves to
have guns do you I only don't have a
problem with arming teachers but
teachers aren't there's a contingency
there's a contingency this is where the
NRA loses me I mean they lose me a lot
of places but but a place like that that
that does seem unreasonable I I can't
understand a guarded a school and I
think if the parkland guard who didn't
do his job had done his job we would be
having a different debate absolutely not
teachers but see here's the thing about
that with respect to this conversation
one of the biggest issues that I've seen
is that we've all kind of separated into
our separate corners and kind of just
lob attacks at each other we all agree
that we want to find a solution to these
issues that's we all agree with that we
just differ about how we go about it so
Irish I can respect your position and
not wanting to arm teachers the way I
look at it is when I look at some of
these these mass shootings that have
happened in the past a lot of these
teachers had to sacrifice themselves to
protect their students and so my mind
goes well why not put them in the best
position to fight back against the evil
person that comes into the class so
instead of making them instead of being
sacrificial lambs the fighters now and
they're willing to die for these
students so why not put them in the
position to fight for because their
teachers they don't want it they don't
want to have that job anymore
anyone whom the guard wants to teach
physics you're absolutely right but the
moment somebody walks into that
classroom with the gun and starts
shooting at kids well they don't have an
option okay so the only options they
have is either sacrifice them so fight
what about background checks no twenty
percent of the people in this country
get their guns without having to pass
any sort of criminal check and when you
say that would give me some some basis
behind that well that if you're talking
about private cells yeah I mean they get
them from a relative gives up to them or
you know it gets passed down or a gun
show or something like that and the NR I
used to be for closing all those
loopholes yeah Wayne Wayne LaPierre
loopholes loopholes well when you say
loopholes what do you mean well here's
what Wayne I'm gonna ask you for this
cuz it's funny because when most people
think of an NRA spokesman they don't
think of you okay fair enough
did they give away in LaPierre okay when
I like to [ __ ] with people's minds Wayne
LaPierre in 1999 we think it's
reasonable provide mandatory instant
criminal background checks for every
sale at every gun show no loopholes
anywhere for anyone what changed
yeah but when you go to a gun show and
you purchase a firearm is it really a
show
I don't know cuz there never been
masturbation no I'm I'm good with
regular masturbation but but a show it
sounds like Annie Oakley it sounds like
you know still the show nonetheless
alright but it's really a sale right
isn't that what a gun show is yeah oh
then you can buy guns but why do they
call it a show well because I when I
first went to a gun show I treat it as
such really you went there because what
it is it's an aggregation of a bunch of
guns that you normally like yeah but
wouldn't it be good if it we had a
hundred percent of people who got it but
background jag wouldn't it wouldn't that
be good sure but how do you go about
doing that from private self standpoint
well I don't know I mean I know you're
against any sort of registry because you
think that leads to confiscation but
well it has before though in America no
in America that's what we're trying to
prevent but it has happened in places
where people use as examples of shining
beacons of what we should do gun control
wise here in America I can't imagine a
country that loves its guns as much as
this country I mean we have almost half
the gun
in the world with 4% of the population I
can't imagine anyone ever tried to take
away people's guns and if the people who
were taking away the guns we're doing it
they're usually the people who like guns
they're law enforcement you know and
argue with that
yeah I'm look I'm I'm a little more gun
reasonable these days now the Trump is
the president but I still think if
people came after me to get even if I
fired back then they could come back
with always superior fire prep the
government is always going to outgun you
okay so why fear well so if ii maybe
understand the second amendment was
written right to protect us and be in a
position to fight off a tyrannical
government so then why not provide us
with the same weapons if what the guns
that i have now are not gonna be enough
actually Gary Wilson
he says the Second Amendment listen to
this I want to get to reaction shows us
just how far the poison of slavery
pervaded the Constitution he says the
second meant was not meant to land let
individuals prevent federal tyranny how
could it but by training our rifles or
handguns on the Army Navy and Air Force
it was meant to guarantee militia to
handle the state's internal problems
essentially the problems of a large
slave population that's a big reason why
we have the Second Amendment because I
really needed to keep the slaves here's
the irony behind that we actually use
the concept of the Second Amendment to
revolt against a country that was
oppressing us right right and then in
the same breath because of the purity of
the language of that Second Amendment I
now sit before you as a gun advocate
with the ability to carry a gun I don't
want to make you mad now you're ready
talking about this I appreciate your
coming on
[Applause]